[Musique]
je m'appelle robinson je suis
dessinateur et j'ai réalisé un carnet de
croquis d'une résidence patrimoine et
création
l'entente sur l'engagisme à la réunion
et qui s'appelle 55 carnets d'un autre
confinement de 55 c'est le nombre de
jours que nous avons passé confiné en
2020 et carnets d'un autre confinement
parce qu'il fait écho au confinement que
les engagés ont vécu au sein du lazaret
de la grande chaloupe
ce carnet et raconte le parcours des
engagés depuis l'arrivée en mer jusque à
l'habitation en passant par le lazaret
numéro un
le laser est numéro 2 l'infirmerie et le
quartier du gol où on tente le prendre
banque mondiale et qui ce qui est un
patrimoine historique du du quartier du
gol à saint louis
l'objectif c'était de travailler en
palimpseste avec donc des croquis qui
représente vraiment la réalité
d'aujourd'hui sur des sur des feuillets
qui sont des extraits d
livres anciens qui recueillait les les
taxes payées par les par les différentes
personnes engagées à la réunion donc
c'est une sorte de 2,2 mise de mise en
relation entre le papier ancien
historique et ses croquis très actuel
avec un écho à une nouvelle écrite par
auguste vinçon un médecin qui a
travaillé dans le lazaret de la grande
chaloupe
cette vision de cette vision très
onirique du d'auguste vinson va avec le
fil directeur du carnet et va permettre
aux visiteurs d'aujourd'hui de se
replonger dans cet univers
cette résidence se décline donc avec un
carnet de croquis mais aussi avec un
site internet qui s'appelle carnet 55
points heureux et qui reprend donc
l'ensemble des des images et des textes
et qui permet une expérience immersive
aux visiteurs et ce carnet se déclinera
aussi en application qui sera une sorte
de l'audio guide pour permettre aux
visiteurs de partager cette expérience
pendant leur visite pour lazard les
résidences patrimoine et création qui
ont été mises en place par le
département
12h07 donc et qui permettent à des
artistes locaux ou internationaux de
donner leur vision d'artiste sur une
histoire particulière créer une oeuvre
originale en lien avec l'histoire de
l'équipement culturel donc pour le
lazaret langage et de la quarantaine et
l'engagisme mais c'est aussi de faire
partager cette heure aucune beau monde
donc dans la mise en place de ces
résidences il ya un temps de médiation
pour l'artiste auprès des publics
d'aidés publiques que le lazaret
accueille tous les journaux près aussi
d'un mix spécifiques
[Musique]